yes um and wanted to
show you some visuals as evidence of
that so let me start
today's unemployment claims data are
another welcome sign of our economic
economy strength as americans get back
to work as of this morning we've had
seven consecutive weeks of decline in
new unemployment claims and to translate
that into uh english for people
listening and watching at home
unemployment claims are basically every
week americans who
no longer who lose their jobs not at
their own fault
they go and they file a claim looking
for unemployment insurance so the drop
in these unemployment claims there's
actually a different chart on this i
don't know if they can pull it up but
that we've seen consecutively over the
last several weeks and months is a good
sign no the other chart would be good
okay great um so you can see here um
just the dramatic drop we've seen since
january all the way down over the last
several weeks that's ultimately a good
sign and today in a new report the oecd
confirmed that we have returned to the
pre-pandemic size of our economy faster
than our global peers while developed
economies around the world are facing
similar challenges on inflation because
a global pandemic is causing global
supply chain issues something we're
experiencing something countries around
the world are experiencing this is
further evidence that the president's
success in getting americans vaccinated
getting economic support to the middle
class means that our recovery has
positioned us better than any of our
peers for continued strong economic
recovery and this new report is evidence
of that so now we go sorry back to the
other chart um as we said before we are
also coming out given we're coming out
of an unprecedented economic shutdown as
a result of the pandemic
we know that small increases in price
can impact the family's budget and what
we're working to do now is both to
address
any
issues that are slowing down the
transfer of goods moving around it's
basically the supply chain is basically
as goods are moving around the world
so we're working to address those
disruptions
makes things make sure goods are getting
shelves faster and easing price pressure
and there's a lot of good data out there
new data shows we're moving more goods
than ever before ports are moving these
goods more quickly and large retail
stores like walmart target best buy and
tj maxx are fully stocked you've seen
ceos put out statements over the last
several days
confirming that and americans should
feel good about the progress that's
being made in addressing these
disruptions and also ensuring that
shelves are stocked at these big retail
stores around the country so
and this gives you kind of some examples
of where we've made progress so if you
look at this this is where where we've
seen you know we've talked a lot about
the ports of los angeles and long beach
where about 40 percent of
volume comes in and we've seen an
increase in uh in goods that are coming
over there year to date compared to the
previous peak this means and a lot of
economists have talked about this that
more goods because people are not
spending their money as much on
on
going to restaurants um and and doing
things that uh that american families
normally do they're buying a lot of
goods people are buying televisions
they're buying uh things online this is
happening around the world um and
there's a 16 increase that's why uh
we've also seen because of the
president's port action plan some
progress that we've made one of the
issues as you all know especially folks
who work in television you've you've
seen containers out there that will were
held for some time we've made progress
on that a 32 percent increase
in the long dwelling containers so
that's a good step forward that means
more goods are moving good positive step
i'd also note and you see this in the
retail sales date and information that's
been put out there that retail um sales
are up up from uh from september 30th of
2020 again further evidence that people
are buying more stuff as we've talked
about and then the last piece i just
wanted to point out here and this is
evidenced by as i talk about these ceos
uh who have put out statements saying
their stores their shelves are stocked
that uh on the shelf availability is now
at 90 percent as of the 14th of november
so just a couple of days ago uh last
piece i just wanted to note here and i
know chris mentioned this yesterday but
since we're talking about all the
different impacts on people's costs and
uh and and how the american people are
navigating this yesterday the president
wrote a letter to ftc chair alina khan
calling her to her attention the
mounting evidence of anti-consumer
behavior by oil and gas companies as the
president noted in his letter prices at
the pump have continued to rise even as
refined fuel costs go down and industry
profits go up obviously that's not the
right correlation
usually prices at the pump correspond to
movements in the price of unfinished
gasoline which is the main ingredient in
the gas people buy at stations but in
the last month the price of unfinished
gasoline is down more than five percent
while gas prices at the pump are up
three percent in that same period and
that is not what obviously that
trajectory should look like and this
unexplained gap between the price of
unfinished gasoline and the average
price at the pump is well above the
pre-pandemic average it's not what we
look to comparatively for years
pre-pandemic
if the gap between the refined fuel
costs and pump prices were at typical
pre-pandemic levels then americans would
be paying nearly 25 cents less per
gallon so clearly that's not how it
should be working that's why the
president sent the letter and this is
clearly a place where
he's of course encouraging asking the
ftc to look into this
i'd also note one of the last things i
promised just lots going on
we're also hosting a meeting of
governors and federal and state
officials on the front lines of helping
families address home heating costs this
winter that's something that especially
in the northeast colder parts of the
country
other parts where energy costs have been
higher has been of concern and an issue
this focus will the focus of the meeting
will be on deploying unprecedented
resources provided by the american
rescue plan including more than doubling
funding for low-income
home energy assistance programs li-heap
as many call it although we hate
acronyms around here as well as
emergency rental assistance that can be
used for utility bills there are a lot
of states and governors who've already
done this with their state and local
funds but this is something that we are
going to play an aggressive role in
working with governors to help implement
to make sure that
lower income families around the country
are able to afford
their heating
this winter and we're also working with
utility companies to help address that
as well
i have a couple other things but i'm
going to stop there because i just want
to get to your questions go ahead okay
thank you
the president just now uh to peter's uh
question uh about the upcoming beijing
the game said that uh when peter asked
if uh diplomatic boycott was under
considerations that it was indeed
something we're considering
could you just
explain what a diplomatic boycott would
mean
i'm assuming that doesn't mean athletes
um it means something narrower and then
secondly coming so soon after the
meetings with president xi
what does that say about the meetings
this last week were they not
constructive that
um that the president would be
considering this big move sure well let
me take the second question first it
doesn't say anything about the meeting
they didn't talk about the olympics
during the meeting it wasn't a topic
that was discussed during the meeting i
would note that we've said from the
beginning the beginning of this
administration as it relates to how we
engage with china that we see it through
the prism of competition not conflict
that is our objective that the president
is going to raise issues where he has
concern and he's going to look for areas
to work together and his lengthy three
and a half hour meeting the other night
was certainly a reflection of that uh
both areas where we could work together
in areas where we have concern were
raised as you all know from the readouts
following uh the meeting uh but you know
there are areas uh that we do have
concerns human rights abuses uh you've
seen not just in words we've used but
certainly in actions we've taken at the
g7 and other sanctions that we have
serious concerns about the human rights
abuses we've seen in xinjiang
and certainly there are a range of
factors as we look at what our presence
would be so i don't have any other
update for you
i certainly understand the interest but
i want to leave the president the space
uh to to make decisions it's possible
that you can just at least broadly i'm
sure a lot of americans that are
interested in the upcoming games and a
lot of athletes want to know what
uh
that could potentially mean what a
diplomatic boycott entails i certainly
understand that i just don't have an
update on on where uh it will what our
presence will be um and then does the
white house any have any reaction to
oklahoman forming national guard members
there uh it doesn't need to abide by
pentagon vaccine rules
uh
sure well
first armor of course the department of
defense is the appropriate place but let
me since you asked me the question uh
what we're talking about here and why
there are requirements in place for
members of our nation's military
including national guard is we need to
ensure that we are
really ready no matter what to protect
the united states and as secretary
austin has conveyed a vaccinated force
is a more ready force
and that is one of the reasons he has
been so um has led on this effort to uh
implement this requirement of
vaccinating the total force including
the national guard so in accordance with
that we've been encouraging all states
to continue to offer the vaccine inform
their members that it is a federal
federal requirement
and we believe and continue to believe
that no leader should be getting in the
way of any action that will ensure or
prevent or hinder operational readiness
for our military which is something
certainly the secretary of defense has
conveyed and one last thing
on
canada's prime minister
called the tax credit that the president
said you'd be
speaking with prime minister trudeau
about a clear violation of the updated
american trade agreement does the white
house
have any response then
we we don't view it that way i think
it's safe to say i would say that in our
view armor the uh the
electric vehicle tax credits is an
opportunity to help consumers in this
country uh it's it's not the first time
that there have been incentives and tax
credits to help
consumers lower prices for consumers
help incentivize a move towards a clean
energy industry something that is good
for our climate certainly yes good for
businesses uh here in the united states
uh something that will help create good
paying union jobs in an industry that's
already starting to head that way but
it's something where consumers would
benefit
and obviously our view is that we have a
great relationship with canada the
president is very much looking forward
to the meeting today and there's a lot
of ways we can discuss working together
on economic issues strategic issues
addressing the global pandemic and i'm
sure they will cover a range of topics
in the meeting today go ahead
so a couple of
questions about bilateral relationships
that are not in focus at the white house
today um so first you were talking about
gas prices
so i wanted to ask you about saudi
arabia
um it's a country that secretary blinken
has described as one where you have a
very strong relationship and yet they
have
time and time again resisted refused
your calls to increase oil production
would that ever hurt your bilateral
relationship would you ever
punish them for that would you would you
ever change that relationship as a
result of that well i certainly don't
want to make a prediction of that from
here but i will reiterate that
we have raised with opec member
countries including saudi arabia even
though we're not a member of opec the
need to ensure that there is available
supply out there on the market i think
the reason why i led by talking about
the ftc letter is because as we've seen
the price of global oil global price of
oil come down we haven't seen the price
of gas come down so there also is a
responsibility for oil companies uh here
in the united states and elsewhere to
make sure that they are not gas gouging
consumers across the country okay one
other um on iran there's been some
reporting that the administration has
been privately floating with allies the
idea that you might give some sanctions
relief or come to some kind of interim
deal in order to get those nuclear
negotiations off to a good start um i
know that your public position thus far
has been that that is not something that
um that you're that you're doing would
you ever consider that is that something
that you would ever consider doing to
get those negotiations i'm not aware of
any change in our position or approach
the negotiations
good thanks jen um
whose decision was it to break with
tradition and not hold a formal press
conference after
the trilateral summit today was that
something requested by the canadians or
the mexicans and why
well i would say first i don't think
it's as scandalous as that in terms of
the back story just to to preface um
there hasn't been a north american
leader summit uh since 2016. so when
we're talking about precedent just to be
clear we're talking about prior to that
uh the president very much of course was
looking forward to hosting prime
minister trudeau and president obador at
the white house today i would note that
in the last three weeks uh the president
has hosted two press conferences three
if you count the one after he uh
announced he did announce the signing of
the bipartisan infrastructure bill where
he took a number of questions uh he's
also including today he's taking
questions from reporters a total of at
least 10 times this month there's a
change in schedule as things move around
as they sometimes do as you know he
signed three important
pieces of legislation today important
for law enforcement that
had broad bipartisan support that moved
everything later in the day and
schedules change and adjust but you saw
him take questions just a few minutes
ago
mexico coming into this
meeting said that it's seeking access to
more vaccines is that something that the
president is planning to
promise today well i know uh part of the
preview that we did last night they
talked about how and and certainly we'll
do a written readout once these meetings
conclude that will be more detailed but
uh how obviously covid and addressing
the covid pandemic will be a part of the
discussion now a big part of that coming
into the meeting from our perspective
was the fact that we had lent or
provided vaccine supply to mexico and
canada and we wanted to talk to them
about providing that supply broadly into
the region something that would
obviously be up to public health
officials in terms of what they may
request i can't speak to that
but certainly we're going to continue to
play a role in addressing the global
pandemic and then very quickly back to
the question about
the chinese olympics is there a timeline
for when the white house would decide
about a diplomatic boycott is it weeks
is it months would you make a decision
closer to the actual date of the
olympics i certainly understand the
question i just want to give the
national security team and the president
uh space to make the decision so i can't
give you a prediction of a timeline
thank you jen grim milestone this week
more than a hundred thousand people died
of drug overdoses in the last year
experts say a lot of that is driven by
fentanyl which is coming across the
southern border in record amounts so why
is not why isn't the administration
doing more to stop the drugs from coming
in
well first i would say that the
president is meeting with the president
of mexico today as you know and that we
work with mexico every day to disrupt
transnational criminal organizations
which are responsible as you know for
the majority of fentanyl heroin and
methamphetamine entering the united
states as well as spreading violence and
insecurity in mexico so during the
summit today we certainly expect
that discussing this topic our joint
goals to combat transnational crime and
terrorism uh this the movement of of of
these type of drugs across the border
would be part of the discussion and when
it concludes we'll provide a readout
okay and then following up on the
meeting with president xi american intel
agencies have told the president they
cannot crack the origins of covet
without china's help president biden had
a chance to ask for china's help
why didn't he
well i would say that the president's
push for
the chinese to be participate more
provide more transparent data and
information we've never held back on
that front we've argued for it publicly
if we argued for it at every level and
the president did talk in his meeting
about the importance of transparency
which is this is exactly an example of
he talked about the importance of
transparency but did he ask president xi
to cooperate specifically with this u.s
intel agency-led investigation into the
origins of kobe peter it's clear that
that's what we want that's what we've
been pressing on
i don't have any more to put to read out
for you from the meeting you're saying
that it's clear is it clear to somebody
who has a zoom meeting with the
president that that's what he means if
that's not what he says
i think the president has spoken
publicly on this a number of times our
national security officials have
conveyed very clearly i don't think it's
a secret that's what we want that's what
we've been pressing
the final one on that are they old
friends or not because the president has
claimed that they're not you claimed
that they're not but then president xi
said that they are
the president didn't say that the
president considers him someone he has
known for some time someone he can have
candid relationships with i can't speak
for how the chinese categorize or
describe people they know in the world i
can only describe how the president
views the relationship go ahead is
mexico doing enough to stem the flow of
migrants into the u.s and i asked that
question amid new numbers that show in
the last year i think it was 1.7 million
individuals who were detained at the
border trying to cross
illegally
this is definitely going to be as you
know peter but just to reiterate a part
of the discussion today every country in
the western hemisphere
has of course been impacted in some ways
by migration events in recent years a
lot of mexico has been as well that's my
that's my point there
and leaders in the region have a shared
interest in humane migration management
we of course our views we have to
address these issues together so this is
certainly an opportunity today to have a
further discussion about it about what
more can be done and certainly more can
be done and should be done yesterday
during that during a preview call in
advance of this a senior administration
official said there is not a real focus
this time around on our borders
for those who are concerned about the
situation at the border why isn't that a
real focus of today's conversation well
i think they also did talk about though
how the root causes of migration
including people who are coming from the
south of mexico or this is how i read
the uh the backgrounder
was going to be a part of the discussion
and i can assure you or others who may
have confusion about that that migration
addressing the root causes ensuring
we're doing it in a humane way uh but
but reducing the number of people who
are coming to the border will be part of
the discussion that's one last question
i'm not sure if the white house has a
position on this but i ask because it's
gained a lot of attention the u.s among
uh individuals and frankly around the
world there's a tennis star from china
feng shui who has been missing it seems
for a matter of days if not weeks her
social profile now comes up with nothing
does the white house have concerns have
any comment any position on that
situation given she's such a high
profile individual who spent a lot of
time playing tennis frankly in the
united states yeah we have of course
seen the reports we unfortunately just
don't have any additional information on
it or additional comment
good thanks uh i know you might not be
able to give a concrete update on the
idea of a diplomatic boycott but two
senators senator tom young and tim kaine
told our hill reporter ally pokornon
that their understanding is the
administration does support this idea of
a diplomatic boycott so can you at least
tell us if the president has been
talking to senators about this i mean
the president was just asked about this
and gave an answer of course we're in
regular touch at a range of levels with
members of congress about a range of
issues including our relationship with
china and including an issue like this
that there's been a lot of reporting and
interest in but uh beyond that i don't
have an update given he just answered
the question himself and then sort of
following up on the um the question
about the electric car
tax credits but kind of more broadly
maybe you can talk to whether there's
been any concern from the white house
heading into these meetings today
whether the president's big push to make
things in america and buy american
in the long term could be right now
making it harder to get mexican canada
on board to help with some of the supply
chain issues
well our view is that
we have a lot we can work with uh a lot
of work we can do i should say uh with
the canadians on addressing supply chain
issues something that's in our mutual
interest and there's mutual benefit in
doing that we've done a lot of work on
this end we certainly know that the
ability for goods to move effectively
around connecting infrastructure making
sure it's efficient even at a time where
the purchasing of goods is up increased
massively around the world here canada
everywhere around the world that's in
our mutual interest i would say just to
go back to you know what i said in
response to omar's question i mean the
electric vehicles component of the
package is something the president is
personally very excited about because he
believes it's an industry of the future
and industry that can help create a good
good paying union jobs and it will help
consumers it will help incentivize the
purchasing of electric vehicles and the
driving electric vehicle something
that's good for our climate
but all diplomatic relationships have
areas where uh there might be uh tough
topics to discuss where people have
concerns they raise that's the purpose
of these in-person meetings
it doesn't sound like he's interested in
negotiating on that one maybe letting
there be a canadian sort of carved out
for credit tax credits for as you said
as he said they're excited as he said
they're going to discuss it and we'll
see what they discuss and we'll give you
guys a readout but i think in response
dahmer's question i was just answering
how we view it
and
of course reiterating the president's
excitement about this component of his
package go ahead thanks jen while he's
meeting with the mexican president today
do you expect them to come to an
agreement on returning to the trump era
remain in mexico policy
i don't believe that's intended to be a
big topic at this meeting
today i think it was previewed as not a
not a major topic of discussion so i
wouldn't anticipate that okay and the
house could vote as soon as tonight to
advance the build back better bill for
the president he has touted this of
course as he did yesterday in michigan
as a big boost for the middle class is
he comfortable where the current
provisions stand for these state and
local tax deductions given it would be a
pretty significant tax break for the
wealthy well let me start by first um
you know obviously wasn't what he
proposed in his initial package as you
know but uh just to come back to that um
the president uh also though it's been
conveyed to him by leaders in the house
and senate that this needs to be
included in order for this legislation
to move forward and he certainly
understands that and takes uh these
legislators who've been doing this a
long time very effectively
at their word but even as we look at the
content of it it's a long-term
sustainable reform in our view that
doesn't add at all to the deficit over
the decade and over that period will
mean that millionaires and billionaires
actually pay more than they would
otherwise
it would raise the cap to 72 500 fully
paying for itself across a decade it's a
sustainable solution in our view that
means those with lower incomes would be
able to fully write off their state and
local taxes
so it is a component that wasn't
initially proposed this is a part of
compromise
it's not something that would add to the
deficit as it's pro as it is concluded
in the package and uh certainly we're
comfortable with it moving forward you
are comfortable with it moving forward
again this is not what we proposed but
this is compromise it's in the package i
just wanted to give you a sense of uh of
where it stood does the president
support the senate adding an income
threshold to that
i'm not going to parse different
components that are being discussed as
we're working to finalize it
the president again this is a part of
the bill that the president that has
been proposed that is important to key
members as you all know uh that's why
it's in the package uh the president's
excitement about this is not about the
salt deduction it's about the other key
components of the package and that's why
we're continuing to press for it to move
forward go ahead thanks so much um in
regards to the supply chains
i wanted to ask how serious is the
administration considering uh the option
of near shoring
you know creating incentives to
encourage some manufacturing to move
from china to mexico for example so far
the focus has been on as she was saying
earlier buy american policies is near
shoring one of the things the
administration is taking seriously
i'd have to talk to our economic team of
whether that is one of the
top areas or top policies they're
looking at as you know we're looking at
a range of ways we can continue to
build on the progress that in our view
we've made already to date
that includes making sure we're
implementing as it relates to the
infrastructure bill the ports piece on
the early end of that because we know
that's a key component of making sure
goods are moving effectively around the
country but i will ask them if that's
something that is under consideration
could you respond to senator rubio's
decision to place a hold on biden's
nominee for the ambassador to china
obviously a key position
rubio's concerns
are that nicholas burns
has some business relationships in china
well i would first say that anyone who
knows nick burns's background knows that
he is
eminently qualified for this position
he's somebody who
could effectively do the job from the
first day he he is uh he is serving in
it uh and he is somebody also this is a
country where we vitally need an
ambassador at a time where we have a lot
of business engagement follow-up work to
to be done so we are certainly eager to
see his uh nomination move forward what
can i ask you for give me for an update
on fed timing
you don't have to you don't have to
apologize it's okay it's an important
topic
i have to apologize yeah
oh wow sick burn
you as one as well think of the dna yes
in a dna
it still remains as chris said yesterday
uh that he intends to make a decision in
advance of thanksgiving and hopefully
all of you financial reporters can rest
easily with your turkey and mashed
potatoes or whatever you like to eat
that you don't have to be chasing it by
then is that an announcement that we can
expect to be for the other open
positions or is it just the chair that
he's going to think about
i i don't have an update beyond that but
i i think you can certainly expect the
the nominee for the that he will make a
decision and we'll have more to say
before thanksgiving on the chair on the
spr you discussed with president xi the
notion of jointly releasing reserves can
you say whether you've had discussions
with other countries about whether the
us would consider a joint release of oil
reserves
so the president we have national
security members the national security
team i should say have discussed with a
range of uh countries including china as
was noted in the readout um the need to
meet the supply demands out there over
the longer term as well i don't have an
update i know you weren't exactly asking
about china but about that um but uh
that is an ongoing conversation and one
we're having with a number of partners
i don't have additional details i will
see if there's more we can provide a
quiz way but you know uh right whatever
you say in country and i'll wink or not
i don't know
finally reconciliation uh or sorry dead
limit uh schumer and mcconnell are
meeting on that stage the white house
think reconciliation is the best path
forward or do you prefer another path on
raising the debt limit after secretary
ellen's timing that she provided earlier
this week yes and for others who didn't
see it or may not watch it as closely
secretary yellen put another update
letter out there
giving kind of a rough timeline of
around december 15th of when we would
you know
have more questions about whether we
could pay our bills at that point you
know our view is that it has been done
81 times if i'm getting my math
correctly
through regular order we saw that happen
a few weeks ago that is certainly our
preferred path uh we think there's no
reason to mess with the to fool around
with the faith and credit of the united
states and that's certainly what we're
going to continue to press forward on go
ahead back on tax credits it's not just
the canadians that are upset
tesla is upset toyota is upset because
the the bill as it's written in the
house would give a leg up to the
companies that happen to have contracts
with the uaw how committed is the
president to keeping that provision in
the building
the president is pretty committed to uh
the
bill providing good paying union jobs
the president seemed to say this morning
i think i heard him say that he would
take questions after he meets with the
leaders today
do you know more what we can expect in
that regard
well he just took questions a little bit
ago so we'll see what the end of today
looks like and the president wants to
take questions that's certainly his
right to take questions should we expect
a press conference tonight or tomorrow
i would not expect no but you can take
questions you can you can ask questions
in any format right i don't think you
need a formal embroidered chair for it i
don't think we would like we would like
a press conference
okay go ahead thanks ben um on
immigration several democratic lawmakers
outside groups administration officials
have told us they don't think that the
administration has a cohesive
immigration policy and that's
contributed to the higher numbers the
record numbers that we're seeing at the
border do you think the administration
has a cohesive immigration policy and
how would you characterize it
we do uh we have a
a bill that the president proposed and
put forward on his first day in office
uh we believe there not only needs to be
a more uh fair uh system a humane system
but we need that we believe there needs
to be a more effective asylum processing
we need that we believe there needs to
be smarter border security investment um
and we believe that there needs to be
more done to address the root causes
that is all a part of the president's
proposed legislation and we are eager to
work with anyone in the house or senate
democrat or republican who wants to work
with us on
on putting forward moving forward on
long overdue immigration reform you know
in the meantime the legislation is
stalled in congress in the meantime do
you think there's a cohesive um strategy
that the white house is implementing
based on just executive actions and what
you guys do at the border and trying to
control the numbers well again i would
note that those who may be critical
could be a part of the solution
in working together to address
what we know is a often cyclical
challenge of people coming larger
numbers of people coming to the border
yes increases more recently but we've
seen it in the past as well and
as we see challenges and processing at
the border that is not going to be
solved with a short-term solution we
need a longer-term solution so i would
note that we have seen progress as we
look at numbers
over the course of time month by month
but we need a longer term legislation
comprehensive reform
put in place and we welcome the interest
of anyone to work with us on that
plan to attend the world economic forum
in davos
i don't have any uh travel or anything
to preview for early next year it now
feels like it's coming soon even though
i long felt like it was long ago so no
plans to preview but uh but if there's
anything more we happy to update you all
on that go ahead hi jen what is the
president's reaction to the dhs
inspector general's decision not to
investigate the horseback patrol
incident in del rio there's still an
inquiry by the office of professional
responsibility but there's not an
announced
its completion the president in
september
said there would be consequences
secretary mayorkas said an investigation
would turn around in a week were the
president and secretary too hasty in
those remarks i knew the secretary spoke
to this i think yesterday and i would
just point you to his comments i don't
have an additional comment from here go
ahead
jonathan you're in a different spot i'm
adjusting a different different
viewpoint thank you uh two uh two
questions for you does the white house
having reaction uh to today the governor
of oklahoma called off the execution of
a death row inmate a julius jones just
hours before uh he was to be killed it's
a case though he attracted a lot of
attention from activists students in the
state uh mr jones instead will be given
uh he sent to life in prison without the
possibility of parole
well the president has made clear over
time that he has grave concerns about
whether capital punishment as currently
implemented is consistent with the
values that are fundamental to our sense
of justice and fairness and certainly as
looking at a case like this you reflect
and i think he he and we all reflected
on his point of view or his view and his
policy position in that regard and i'd
note for us on a federal level uh the
attorney general's halted executions at
the federal level can we are in the
process of conducting
an important review of the federal death
penalty and the president believes that
is an important step forward but this as
as you know was a state
level sentence the action needed to be
taken on the state level and so there
wasn't a a real role that the federal
government could officially play in that
regard but certainly the president
president's grave concerns about the
death penalty and the implementation of
that are um you know
i i think are were reflected in how he
viewed this case okay and another matter
just picking up the threat on
ambassadors yeah there's some growing
calls among some democrats for senate
majority or schumer to do things quote
the hard way and perhaps keep the senate
in nights weekends whatever it might be
to get some of these senate these
ambassador conference nominees confirmed
does the white house endorse that
position what more do you guys want to
see
about getting more ambassadors put in
place so very few have been to this
point well one thing that could happen
um if you know just to go kind of full
nerd senate process here is that
a lot of these nominees as you've seen
over there not everyone but many of
these nominees ambassadorial nominees
eminently qualified nominees end up
passing with a majority vast majority
vote i mean democrats and republicans
and they could just be voted through or
passed through through unanimous consent
you don't need to use all the hours on
the floor right to
have the process um
uh proceed where there's hours of debate
um there have been delays and holds as
you know from a variety of individuals
senator cruz is one of them
so
that has been a challenge as well but
certainly we believe that it is far past
time to move forward with these nominees
that
you know we are uh hindered by not
having people and ambassadors in places
around the world at a time and i was you
know i think if you haven't all seen
that the statement by former senate
secretary gates uh he had a pretty
strong compelling statement out there
about the importance of moving forward
with some of these nominees we're at
almost december in the administration so
i i would just say that's how we broadly
view it but it is true also that
leader schumer has is trying to move
forward quite a bit on uh the
legislative agenda he has effectively
and efficiently done that to date and
one of the challenges here of the big
challenge that i don't think should be
under valued or underreported is the
holds is the insistence on lengthy
processes that is really not necessary
in every case go ahead uh some states
have already expanded booster shot
eligibility to all adults does the white
house believe that that should be done
nationwide does the president think that
all adults should be getting their
booster shots now well there's a process
that is underway as you know and we've
said from
back several months ago that once the
fda and the cdc approved
boosters for
individuals over a certain age or once
they go through the process to approve
it we'd be ready with the supply and
we'll be ready with the supply but
science first data first so we'll wait
for the process to proceed concerned
about the rising numbers going into the
holiday season into the winter we're
seeing numbers tick off across the
country right now what everyone else's
plans to deal with that well we're
continuing to implement
vaccination programs of course across
the country we have been encouraged uh
by some of the numbers we've seen in
terms of the uptick of people who are
eligible who are getting their booster
shots about 30 million americans have
done that to date obviously more than
that are eligible so we'd like to see
more people getting booster shots who
are eligible to get that extra
protection against kovid 19 now
especially going into the holiday season
we know now that now that kids age 5 to
11 are eligible that if you get your
vaccine shot you get your first shot now
you'll your kids will be
protected by the holiday season so we're
continuing to press and remind people
that this is a big travel time of year a
big crowd time of year uh winter
obviously colder weather more people
inside and we are
upping our outreach to to emphasize that
go ahead karen thanks yesterday congress
passed a bill to give the congressional
medal of honor to the 13 service members
who were killed in the attack at the
kabul airport some of those families
were critical at the time of the
withdrawal and the president's efforts
to honor their loved ones when will he
sign that legislation and is this
something where he would host something
at the white house to award those medals
to the families
uh well well first let me say that the
president um doesn't look at
the loss they had or the grief that
these families endured through the
political prison and some of them were
critical uh they have every right every
right to speak publicly about their
points of view that continues to be uh
his viewpoint uh in terms of the status
of it i just have to check with our
legislative team on on what that looks
like i'm happy to do that do a ceremony
at the white house is it i don't know
what it looks like yet because i have to
check on the status as you know he met
many of these families back in august
following what i would still say was one
of the worst days of his presidency and
conveyed to them that he would be
open to staying in touch if that was
appealing to them and everybody
deals with and copes with grief the loss
of a loved one in different ways he
remains open to that but um but i don't
have any updates beyond that one quick
one on paid leave there's reportedly an
effort underway by some democrats to
start working on a separate uh paid
leave proposal out of the buildback
better plan
that could have bipartisan support is
this something that the president has
endorsed as a strategy given that the
house has not even voted yet on the go
back better and where it goes in the
senate then well the the president wants
wants paid leave to be in the final
package and of course
it is in the house package and the house
bill that will be voted on
soon
but without prejudging the outcome here
we also know that
it needs to have support in the senate
in order to move forward and that has
been challenging to date but the
president is committed to getting this
done and without getting involved in the
specific legislative tactics of it which
i don't think he's quite engaged with on
this topic at this point
he wants to get paid leave done he
thinks it's long overdue and he's
committed to getting it done
good thanks jeff yesterday oil and gas
companies paid nearly 190 million
dollars for drilling rates on federal
um reserve oil reserves in the gulf of
mexico this comes just after president
guidance at cop26 in the united kingdom
um given that these leases are going to
last well past 2030 does this current
round undermine your albide's pledge to
reduce fuel traffic
i think i may have spoken to this the
other day and i think there's a legal
court case around this on the
implementation or the allowing of these
oil leases to move forward um but i
would say uh so i would refer you to
those comments go ahead katie
talking about a summit where migration
is one of the major issues without
bringing up a policy like remain in
mexico where does the white house think
the proper forum for that is if it's not
one like this
well as you know there are there's uh
legal uh ramifications around this uh
legal discussions around this so i think
that's part of the reason it hasn't been
intended to be a major
focus of discussion but certainly
migration will be as will uh every steps
that can be taken to reduce the number
of people who are coming to the border
coming from central america through
mexico and we believe we can do that in
a cooperative manner and one on vice
president harris um what is the strategy
behind her having her on separate set of
violets today will she be focusing on
different issues with each leader i'm
just wondering what
the thinking is i don't think that's
historically uncommon when leaders come
to the united states to have meetings
with the vice president as well as the
president certainly there are overlaps
of discussions but it gives them an
opportunity to have high level
engagement while they're in the united
states with uh both the president united
of the united states and the vice
president of the united states something
we certainly think sends an indication
about the value we pl place in these
relationships
thank you jen uh there's a growing sense
among world leaders and others that on
foreign policy president biden is
markedly different from former president
trump on tone um but on substance in
some of the ways uh it's very similar
and not that different than uh donald
trump's america first policy so in light
of today's violence and trial i just
want to give you a chance to respond
like what are their examples um so for
instance uh the canadian chamber of
commerce
said told politico today president biden
has doubled down on some of trump's
policies and in other cases taken
actions that are directly against
canada's interests i think the two main
areas would be trade and immigration and
then a little while earlier on the
submarine kerfuffle with the french the
french foreign minister said this is
brutal unilateral and unpredictable
decision reminds me a lot of what mr
trump used to do and i can get you more
examples sure well look i would say i'm
not sure those are that specific and
i've already spoken to the electric
vehicles component uh i think it's hard
for any analyst to look at the
president's approach to re-engaging with
allies around the world
which is something that has been front
and center to the president's approach
to global engagement to rejoining the
paris climate agreement to acknowledging
that climate is one of the biggest
crises we face around the world
to ensuring that we are uh working uh to
promote human rights uh around the world
freedom of press around the world
i think the the list of differences is
probably a laundry list and the list of
similarities probably fits on the back
of a tiny napkin
um on the diplomatic boycott of the
olympics can you give us any sense of a
time frame for one you should expect
that decision i i don't i don't have a
time frame to give you today actually
obviously the olympics are in february
and i want to give the president and the
national security team a little space
but as as any updates are there to
provide we certainly understand the
interests and we'll provide them to all
of you go ahead you talked about the
letter the president wrote to the ftc um
how fast does the president expect that
letter to bring down gas prices
well i think what we're looking at here
is highlighting and elevating an issue
that should be pretty apparent to people
across the country and i would note
since you gave me the opportunity that
in the letter the president also noted
that the two largest oil and gas
companies in the united states measured
by market capitalization just to speak
your kind of language are on track to
nearly double their net income over 2019
so just to give you a sense they're set
to earn 32.9 billion dollars this year
in 2019 the two companies only earned
17.2 billion in combined net income and
i would also note that bp ceo uh said
while announcing an additional 1.25
billion dollar share buyback earlier
this month quote when gas prices are
strong this is literally a cash machine
so that's noted in the president's
letter this is a letter sent to the
chair of the ftc they are of course
independent they make independent
choices i would note that in a previous
letter
that was sent related to
concerns we had about gap oil and gas
mergers they responded
obviously and there have been reports
out there i would note a reuters report
out there that showed that this had had
an impact on oil and gas murder so i
can't predict for you i understand what
you're asking but given the independence
of the ftc
i would point you to them uh but
certainly we see this discrepancy
between the um uh the come the price
that is coming down as it relates to oil
and the price of gas is concerning so
any consideration to reversing some of
the policies um that led to this maybe
reconsidering the keystone pipeline as
uh the prime minister of canada is here
well i think the problem with that
argument is that the keystone pipeline
uh isn't even really functioning i mean
it was only partially built it isn't
even really functioning so suggesting
that uh changing that would lower the
price of gas i don't know that that
makes
sense look at where it will be in the
looks out and you substantive
future and canceling keystone pipeline
not allowing other pipelines to go
forward or challenging other pipelines
might reduce or cause some concern in
the market oh we look at every pipeline
on an individual basis the president
made the decision when only about i
think eight percent of the pipeline had
been built not to move forward as we
looked at the environmental impacts and
weighed them with the economic impacts
um and the decision was certainly made
so uh there's a range of options on the
table i unfortunately don't have
anything more to preview for you today
but certainly lowering the cast the cost
of gasoline something that people around
the world as you know are experiencing
not just here in the united states is of
utmost concern and a priority to the
president a canadian day thank you uh
jen two quick questions the first one i
just want to follow up to the previous
question trade commercial uh trade
protection policies are perceived as
just as intransigent
this administration as
trump's uh policies how do you
distinguish those
give me more information what way you're
talking about the electric vehicles
component for instance uh lumber also
the same attitude is adopted by this
administration as a by the previous one
in on and on lumber in which way are you
talking about tariffs or what specific
component
how difficult it is for canadians to
access the american market or favor the
americans understand that the president
is fighting for good middle-class jobs
as they keep repeating but it's good
that it'll cause jobs on the other side
of the border that are killed by this
attitude
well i would again reiterate a little
bit of what i've said before one they're
going to have a discussion about all
these issues and as you've seen
the prime minister trudeau and his
delegation as you know from reporting on
them will certainly raise this and other
issues in the in the meetings and we'll
do a readout of that as i'm sure they
will do a read out of that
but the president's view continues to be
that
ensuring that investing in the electric
vehicle industry here in the united
states something that helps consumers by
lowering the cost of electric vehicles
making them accessible by dramatically
lowering the cost of purchasing an
electric vehicle by i believe about
twelve thousand five hundred dollars
makes it accessible to people in this
country that's also good for our climate
something we very much agree with
canadian leaders on and the need to take
steps on here in the united states as
one of the world's biggest emitters so
that's a part of the discussion too so i
would say
again that i think there are far more
differences across the board and i think
probably people from the former
president's team would probably agree
with this as well and their approach to
foreign policy then there are
similarities
but this is an area where the president
believes good uni uh good paying union
jobs is important to our market here but
also uh that investing in a clean energy
industry that will help create jobs in
the future is imperative but lots of
work we can do with the canadians it's
been a month now that 16 americans and
one canadian were kidnapped in haiti
what is the administration has been
doing what has the admission been doing
well we've had we have a significant
presence on the ground including with
law enforcement officials from the fbi
and others who are working
constantly to bring these individuals
home i wish i had an update for you
today i know everybody's seeking an
update but unfortunately there's nothing
i have to report
at this moment
go ahead in the back so russia said that
um
recent conversation between uh
national security adviser uh sullivan
and his russian counterpart
uh patricia
was
part of the preparation for for a next
contact between president biden and
putin
so are you planning such a meeting or
phone call and uh
are you satisfied with the results
of the geneva summit given the current
situation around the tensions around
ukraine and the situation the polish
galatian border
well as you noted we have held
discussions with russian officials um
about ukraine and u.s russia relations
recently and as we announced yesterday
the national security adviser spoke with
the secretary of the russian security
council about regional and global
matters of concern i don't have anything
to preview for you in terms of an
additional contact or call or anything
like that with president putin but
certainly after their summit
earlier this summer we agreed there
would be continued levels of contact and
engagement at a high level and that has
proceeded since that point in time
i am not ruling out that the president
of the united states will speak with the
president of russia at some point in the
future true go ahead
oh well i was going to go right behind
you because today is also a mexico day
the north america leadership has many
subjects on the table energy you said
organized crime of course kobe and
certainly usmca
in all of these areas
what do you
what does the united states government
need to see to consider this submit this
summit successful especially
in terms of the mexican government do
you expect any agreement today
and in which areas thank you jen sure so
you know at the bottom line is today is
an opportunity to resume uh a level of
engagement with the canadians and the
mexicans in their leadership at the
leadership level that had been stalled
for four years hadn't happened since
and it's an opportunity to build on
discussions that these leaders were also
a part of whether it was the g20 cop 26
in different capacities so today is an
opportunity for leader to leader
engagement have a discussion about a
range of challenges we all face whether
it's improving vaccine distribution and
pandemic preparedness something that is
certainly on the minds of all leaders
strengthening north american supply
chains enhancing competitiveness
concrete actions on reducing methane
emissions follow-up to the cop26 summit
and developing a regional compact on
migration and protection for the
americas in terms of what will come out
of here we'll have the the meetings have
a couple of more hours so i'll let them
proceed before i preview that but
certainly the president was looking
forward to the opportunity to engage
face to face have discussions about
these important vital issues uh with
these leaders
shelby okay and we'll do shelby last one
thanks uh osha suspended its vaccine
implementation and enforcement because
of a court order
given this update is the administration
still urging businesses to move forward
with
the president's vaccine and weekly
testing rule and are you still working
off of that january 4th compliance
deadline
we are let me be very clear our message
to businesses right now is to move
forward with measures that will make
their workplaces safer and protect them
their workforces from covid19
that was our message after the first
stay issued by the fifth circuit that
remains our message and nothing has
changed i would note that recent polling
i think that just came out yesterday
showed that 60 of businesses are moving
forward with measures that keep their
workplaces safe they're essentially
implementing components or versions of
these vaccine requirements because they
know it's in the interest of their
workforces to protect their workforces
to make sure they can bring more people
back to the workforce and we certainly
see that as a positive sign so we are
still heading towards the same timeline
the department of justice is vigorously
defending uh the emergency temporary
standard in court and we are confident
in osha's authority all right thanks
readout of the everyone that i suppose
just happened did he meet with the
president or with staff he was not in
the meeting with the mexican president
and the canadian president that would
just make an added component of today um
i believe he was uh he was participating
in a swearing-in ceremony for dr gupta
uh per uh dr gupta's request
thanks everyone
you